bene tutti ragazzi ben vedere questo
video sono siamo sul canale giusto
allora rock swing blues ragazzi mi avete
dato un consiglio
fondamentale secondo me per i prossimi
episodi come io ultimamente sto facendo
un po di episodi speciali di fv stimato
fatto il maggior numero di impossible
fattibili in dieci minuti no ea quanto
pare siete tanti impazziti per il rock
swing detto perché il prossimo bisogno
non lo fai solo di rock swing per vedere
quanti lops rifinisce i dieci minuti
quindi non sarà questo l'episodio però
mi è piaciuta un sacco come idea grazie
a chi l'ha scritto probabilmente di
chiama via
pippo gamer 15 però questo livello il
tuo onore nel prossimo episodi via
cristallo livello 10 minuti quanti rock
swing e ska fare dieci minuti se avete
voglia di provarci voi scrivetelo nei
commenti qui sotto
così nel prossimo video vedo se riesco a
battere il vostro rosso record di rob
singh nel frattempo hanno fatto uno e ci
ho messo un minuto quindi già partiamo
male prove prossimo episodio faremo st
robben tanto workshop chi è che si
incazzato mi fanno morire agazzi quando
faccio risvolto e vedo le scritte vicino
alla gente tipo lui ha bevuto tutto il
tuo latte senza permesso va bene viaro
l'attentato 60 di quella che lei ha
distrutto il tuo nuovo gaming setup lui
ha promesso di darti un cani errata ti
ha dato un topo ma che problemi
lui ha rubato il tuo huawei p30 pro non
cela l'uovo ip 30 proprio grazie ma come
è rimasto offeso così c'è scritto sono
giocate di leggere la scritta già
scritto lui ti ha colpito a scuola con
questo film
questa picozza quella di che c'è per
terra intanto in questo momento vi è
cresciuto un bene fortissimo e la
piccozza li sta salvando la vita quindi
a per averne lui a chi ha urinato nel
letto luke bravo che orini sempre chi
distingue lui ti ha dato un pugno nelle
scale e il tipo che ha assassinato la
mia famiglia rimasto lì in piedi intanto
io ho vinto
va bene che bello leggere le iscrizioni
di happiness ragazzi il parkour degli
dèi sentito così un po you are next
machito sorella sipro ti devi togliere
non sono problema sfida per noi ragazzi
fermi sono morto ma ho fatto una trovata
incredibile fatemeh a rivedere vi prego
fa che roba là che roba spiegami come ho
fatto sta cosa
bellissimo come fossero il giocatore di
happiness senza denti ragazzi ma e non
si può far vincere solo
il mezzo di locomozione no fermi tutti
in artico che quel problema speedup che
cosa devo sfida a fare ma non era una
caduta da una caduta fake infatti non
capivo brest e button è proprio un
parkour degli dèi questo c'è proprio da
sé che cammino nell'aria è diventato un
boltro ma come pro il wing dove centrare
quello ti prego non sbagliare naipaul
trovo adesso è un volto mamma mia che
brutto tiro è un mostro semplice zio sam
ma parco demonio tiro là davanti la
falda avanti perché non ho propulsione
c'è un vetro incastrato nei piedi dai
che tiro è quello madonna tra poco i
suoi paese che ti dico io al traguardo
di estremo vender molla ma lavorava lì
sballati bravo parco demoni vado io vado
io me ne sbatto entro io nel traguardo
te lo giuro che ce la faccio vai
trascinati scarso ide entrò nel tratto
di tiro io le palle come dico io
e sembra una frase brutta di raptor dei
fan non sono riuscito a vincere dai
lancio la gamba non riesco a vincere
neanche con la gamba
eccolo eccolo ma ci credo non riesco a
prenderla vittoria ma dai vaghe sfiga
incredibile con mille tiri non sono
riuscite ben nove ragazzi che
liberamente ma neanche se secondo la
probabilità sul milione di sbagliare
wojtyla tirati su
prendi le per cortesia prendi le e segna
non è di chi no va bene va bene va bene
lo stesso fai come ronaldo bravo dai è
facilissimo a un cestista nato alla
russian poco fa un po di povera celotti
prego fa che a parte l'inno russo non è
proprio lì non lo so questo ma panino è
una specie di poco è un po lo fai adesso
la russia bene l'america c'è l'america
vai sul livello del comunismo russia
musi chance vodka va bene questo livello
68 per chi prende la matrioska
vi prego mettete la gigantografia di
putin da qualche parte di temi che lava
del merapi
questo non è ma che musica è questa
ragazza ma che musica ascoltata in
russia lenin sto male ma perché diego
marcon lo devo pure devo recuperarlo
bene il cremlino attenzione all ave
ragazzi quanto con sottolivello superare
e vabbè distrutto la russia va bene
l'aquila con la topi a testa attenzione
benissimo ci siamo c'è ancora
qualcos'altro
thanks for play bellissimo mi è piaciuto
soprattutto la musica orecchiabile world
tour e poi vedere uno smartbook quanto
può essere indie per prema ca4 spalle
devo ammazzarne come faccio scusami come
faccio a utilizzare quattro spade per
ammazzarli tutti ti rendi conto di
quanti sono noti ma click allora prova
allora senza prove
provo con quattro spade ragazzi
impossibile flickinger formare sword
cioè se clicchi li carica mente di altre
squadre ma voglio provarci sono proprio
bravo in questi giochi
vogliamo provarci senza soltanto con
queste quattro e che potrebbe essere
veramente difficile però credo in me
stesso ragazzi devo sfruttare al massimo
la potenza liste spade c'è proprio una
difficoltà per nove mesi ci pensa però
la forza nelle braccia tale da poter
parlare varas ti brucio è impossibile ok
peccato che non è passato nessuno pronti
roma buono bravo dichiara così anche
prima cava che molto difficile
bene
robben
come no fermi era già difficile farli
fuori con quattro spade con una penso
sia il record del mondo allora click
parkour c'è ma ma come ma com'è
possibile cioè un livello dove devo
andare
ma com'è possibile che figata non
sembrano ancora più mi sembra sembra
ragazzi heal the world outgames lo
ricordate ragazzi the world game quello
che era affatto corfù bettino piccolo
con una figata
il portale vabbè dai geniale è veramente
la [ __ ] come ha fatto fare sta roba
va bene andiamo avanti teoricamente ma
io non posso cliccar è solo sulla
vittoria vincerlo cioè comunque ragazzi
nel 2019 le auto voleranno invece happy
with a questi livelli teoricamente
dovrei com'è e allora sei stronzo gli fa
compagnia ma forse devo cliccare non
l'avevo schiacciare allora mi hai rotto
le balle per un'ora e mezza gli hai
fatto bene tutti indietro 7 schifoso ok
è stato estenuante fare sesso diverso
[Musica]
non ho capito al bunga bunga a ok questo
poi da un botto che non lo faccia e si
vede devo praticamente prendere
l'arpione in aria e infilzare la zia la
zia quella qua sotto
devi prendere levi bravo no non fa
niente devi prendere la città di sotto
di allora ma allora eccolo presa beh no
allora e non è difficile praticamente
prendere la tipa di sotto in fissa
no non è difficile ragazzi impegni
magari non è così facile ve lo assicuro
allora se tu prendi l'arpione così ti
fai fare un g i ragazzi gioco è prevista
cinque minuti
capitemi non è così facile ma sapete che
avete anno tipo delle dinamiche diverse
sedi cambio subito potrebbe essere che
non lasciarci ai miti visi sono ciò che
manco prende la reazione però è di sì se
ormai questo livello da ed i ragazzi non
non ne sono sicuro è salva devo tentare
di infilzarla o che ho dritto proprio
dove non puoi provare sentimenti lo so
che mi ha funzionato per questo che ho
fatto mi dispiace e non vorrei fare
niente di strano però mi potresti a meno
ridare l'arpione la fiom quindi dai
l'arpione per cortesia e importante mi
serviva vabbè facciamo che te lo tieni
tienitelo fa niente
la mia vita fa schifo c'era anche un
finale bobba becca carica calca imposti
col capo pula ca cafu perfetto buona
prova
ciao signora kakà boop proviamo a vedere
se son curioso veramente di capire che
l'importanza di livello hai fatto
incredibile era solo una prova va tra
l'altro è molto anche difficile ai a
niente per vincere devo devo aggrapparmi
a qualcosa di sopra come faccio io devo
vincere un livello che in non è
fattibile aiaf attenzione lasciano più
traguardi ma chrome e ragazzi posso
provare a vincere livello di kakà pop
uso se mi impegno potrei farcela ragazzi
pensa che sta riducendo la mia vita
questo provare un livello di kakà vv
ma potrebbe andargli peggio nella mia
esistenza attenzione
[Musica]
kakà fu quando hai fatto sto livello
l'hai fatto nel 2006 ma neanche troppo
tempo fa la nota spero che il video vi
sia piaciuto spero che kakà mutu sia
soddisfatto della mia prestazione io con
quello con l'episodio bello è comunque
farò rock swing solo rock swing in dieci
minuti vediamo mattina esco a fare spero
di riuscire a fare un buon risultato ma
per oggi conclude mi piace che le siete
delle sezioni schiacciate la bellissima
campanella che vedete vicino al tris
critiche molto importante e noi come
sempre ci vediamo l'anno prossimo video
dei ragazzi
[Musica]